Additional precautions,
there are different types of,
contact points
for diseases
contaminated by direct or indirect contact,
the strange droplets
for pathogens transmitted by droplets
for example,
whooping cough.
Aerial precaution
for airborne diseases,
for example,
tuberculosis,
chickenpox.
Have 1 basic hand hygiene
before after any patient,
technical contact,
soap or hydroalcoholic solution,
1 personal protective equipment,
E country, the gloves,
single use,
change between patients,
masks,
respiratory protection,
especially in case of infectious diseases,
regular changes,
especially during contact with body fluid,
1 surface cleaning and disinfection,
regular cleaning with appropriate disinfectants,
material,
or disinfection after each use.
Waste management,
separation,
medical, sharp,
infectious or chemical waste,
elimination,
compliance with procedures for
limit the risk of contamination,
1 isolation of patients in case of infection
Yes,
installation of an isolation chamber.
The difference between
standard and complementary,
the caves
standards are basic measures that apply
to all patients,
that complementary precautions are measures
additional information suitable for patient management
specific
with highly resistant pathogens or in.